This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. We begin today with the story of an economic bubble, or to be more precise, Armenia. This mania took place in Amsterdam in the 1630s. Picture a city of canals, elegant townhouses, and a populace obsessed with one thing. Tilted to cope, tilted to cope, copied you to tell. Tulips. Tomorrow the double worth, best to buy from you, leaven, tilted to cope, tilted to cope. Amsterdam was the site of a big flowers market.
这里是Hidden Brain，我是Shankar Vedanta。今天我们从一个经济泡沫的故事开始，或者更准确地说，是关于亚美尼亚的故事。这场狂热发生在17世纪30年代的阿姆斯特丹。想象一下，那是一座运河纵横、联排别墅优雅的城市，而那里的居民痴迷于一件事。郁金香。明天价值翻倍，最好从你那儿买，郁金香。阿姆斯特丹曾是一个大型花卉市场的所在地。
It still is. People would trade tulips, and there were some tulips that were especially beautiful, they thought. And so people wanted those, and the price started going up. This is economist Robert Schiller and when he says prices started going up, what he means is, they started going up a lot. People were getting rich trading in tulips. One tulip would be the same value as a whole house. One tulip could hold as much value as a house. Now historians say they only found a few examples of this, but even more modestly priced tulips
现在依然如此。人们会交易郁金香，他们认为有些郁金香特别漂亮。于是人们想要这些花，价格就开始上涨。这是经济学家罗伯特·席勒，当他说价格开始上涨时，他的意思是，它们开始大幅上涨。人们通过交易郁金香变得富有。一株郁金香的价值相当于一整栋房子。一株郁金香可以拥有和房子一样的价值。现在历史学家说他们只发现了几个这样的例子，但即使是价格更适中的郁金香
could sell for what would today be thousands of dollars. From a distance of nearly 400 years, the Dutch tulip mania of the 1630s might seem absurd. But the flowers were away for the residents of Amsterdam to convey that they were cultured and influential. The tulips had great symbolic value. They told an amazing story. This week on Hidden Brain, the powerful way in which stories and psychology shape our economic lives, how narratives affect not just the purchases we make as individuals, but the fate of our entire economic system. Most people think of the economy as following a set of fairly scientific principles. I buy more if things are cheap.
也能卖到相当于今天数千美元的价格。从近400年后的今天来看，17世纪30年代的荷兰郁金香狂热似乎很荒谬。但对于阿姆斯特丹的居民来说，这些花是传达他们有文化、有影响力的一种方式。郁金香具有巨大的象征意义。它们讲述了一个惊人的故事。本周在Hidden Brain节目中，我们将探讨故事和心理学塑造我们经济生活的强大方式，以及叙事如何不仅影响我们个人的购买行为，还影响我们整个经济系统的命运。大多数人认为经济遵循一套相当科学的原则。如果东西便宜，我就买得多。
I buy less if they're expensive. The nation's gross domestic product or GDP grew at a stronger than expected rate of two and a half percent of the economy. Or say I run a company. I hire people if it looks like the economy is growing. I cut back if it looks like things are going to tank. The rate of hiring 4 percent accelerated hiring, you can see there mostly just going down. back if it looks like things are going to tighten. If I run the federal reserve, economic indicators tell me whether to raise or lower interest rates. The central bank is cutting interest rates
如果东西贵，我就买得少。国家的国内生产总值（GDP）以高于预期的2.5%的速度增长。或者假设我经营一家公司。如果经济看起来在增长，我就雇人。如果看起来经济要崩溃，我就缩减规模。招聘率，4%的加速招聘，你可以看到大部分都在下降。如果看起来情况要紧缩，我就缩减规模。如果我经营美联储，经济指标会告诉我是否要提高或降低利率。中央银行正在降息
for the third time since July. It all looks very rational, very mathematical. very mathematical. With this picture and neglect of fundamental aspect of economic life, we live in a world of stories. The stories that we tell in news reports around the water cooler and conversations with friends and family, these stories profoundly shape the trajectory of the economy. Economist Robert Schiller's new book explores this idea. It's called Narrative Economics.
这是自7月以来的第三次。这一切看起来非常理性，非常数学化。非常数学化。有了这种观点，就忽略了经济生活的一个基本方面，我们生活在一个充满故事的世界里。我们在新闻报道中、在茶水间、在与朋友和家人的谈话中讲述的故事，深刻地塑造了经济的轨迹。经济学家罗伯特·席勒的新书探讨了这个想法。书名是《叙事经济学》。
The winner of the 2013 Nobel Prize in Economics, Robert Schiller says his interest in the relationship between stories and the economy goes all the way back to his early college days. He was an economics major, but he took a history course that examined the Great Depression. He was struck by the disconnect between the economic ideas he was learning about, and the stories he read about how people behaved in the real world. People didn't sound like the people described in my economic theory. They seemed to be fetish and vulnerable to crazes and new ideas and then they drop them and forget them. It just seemed like there's a note of reality that has been lost when
2013年诺贝尔经济学奖得主罗伯特·席勒说，他对故事与经济之间关系的兴趣可以追溯到他大学早期。他主修经济学，但他选修了一门研究大萧条的历史课。他对自己所学的经济学思想与他读到的关于人们在现实世界中行为的故事之间的脱节感到震惊。人们听起来不像我的经济理论中描述的那样。他们似乎很迷信，容易受到狂热和新思想的影响，然后又抛弃并忘记它们。这看起来就像是现实中丢失了一些东西，当
we separate out departments. History department has something to offer. So does the psych and sociology department, etc. But we tend to be in academia, we tend to be polarized, or more than polarized, and it's comparmentalized. And all my life, ever since, thought that I wanted to read what these other people were saying, as well as what my economists people are saying. Because of course, there are all just different ways to understand the human condition, right? I mean, psychologists and anthropologists and sociologists and economists, I mean they're all basically trying to understand why people do what they do, they're just using different tools. And political scientists. Yeah. Yeah, so we need all these perspectives. Don't be too
我们将各个部门分开时。历史系有其价值。心理学系和社会学系也是如此，等等。但我们在学术界往往是两极分化的，或者说不仅仅是两极分化，而是被割裂的。从那以后，我一生都想读读这些人以及我的经济学同行们在说什么。因为当然，这些都只是理解人类状况的不同方式，对吧？我的意思是，心理学家、人类学家、社会学家和经济学家，他们基本上都在试图理解人们为什么做他们所做的事情，他们只是使用了不同的工具。还有政治学家。是的。是的，所以我们需要所有这些视角。不要太
compartmentalized. It may carry you for a while, but if you don't know what's happening in other realms of thought, you might miss the big picture. Robert says these realms of thought can help us decode things that otherwise seem puzzling about the economy. Take for example the story of a paper written by a mysterious mathematician in 2008. The author went by a pseudonym. Satoshi Nakamoto. Satoshi Nakamoto.
被割裂。它可能会让你走一段路，但如果你不知道其他思想领域正在发生什么，你可能会错过大局。罗伯特说，这些思想领域可以帮助我们解读经济中那些看起来令人困惑的事情。以2008年一位神秘数学家撰写的论文为例。作者使用了一个化名。中本聪。中本聪。
Who is Satoshi Nakamoto? Satoshi Nakamoto is a fake name for somebody. He's the myth. I mean, he doesn't know who he is. Some people claim to be Satoshi Nakamoto, but we have not seen any definitive proof. When you ask about the creator, who created this, who invented this, they must be real genius.
谁是中本聪？中本聪是某人的假名。他是一个神话。我的意思是，没人知道他是谁。有些人声称自己是中本聪，但我们没有看到任何确凿的证据。当你问及创造者，是谁创造了这个，是谁发明了这个，他们一定是个真正的天才。
Everyone's like, we have no idea. The reason Satoshi Nakamoto created such a stir? This person, whose identity is still unknown, came up with a new type of currency. Bitcoin. The first successful cryptocurrency. The story was that Nakamoto was able to invent a currency that could function without the help of any government, even against the opposition
每个人都说，我们毫无头绪。中本聪引起如此轰动的原因是什么？这个身份至今不明的人，发明了一种新型货币。比特币。第一个成功的加密货币。故事是这样的：中本聪发明了一种可以在没有任何政府帮助下运作的货币，甚至是在反对
of any government. Bitcoin emerged as the digital currency that in theory could not be manipulated by a central authority. And it would be smart young cosmopolitan people all over the world who would secure this decentralized system. It's a wonderful story and especially wonderful since nobody could figure out who Satoshi Nakamoto really was. He never can't be found. No one has met him. How did he do that? It's an amazing story. Robert makes the case that Bitcoin's bread because it was a tale with surprise and intrigue. A genius mathematician invents a cryptocurrency and becomes a billionaire.
任何政府的情况下。比特币作为一种数字货币出现，理论上它不能被中央权威操纵。而全世界聪明、年轻、有国际视野的人将保护这个去中心化的系统。这是一个美妙的故事，尤其美妙的是没人能弄清楚中本聪到底是谁。他永远找不到。没人见过他。他是怎么做到的？这是一个惊人的故事。罗伯特认为比特币之所以兴起，是因为它是一个充满惊喜和阴谋的故事。一位天才数学家发明了一种加密货币并成为了亿万富翁。
It sounds like the plot of a movie. If I was making that movie, one sub plot I would include is the story of the singer, Lily Allen. Lily Allen received an offer to get paid for a performance in Bitcoin. She turned it down. That was the most momentous error you can imagine, because she would be a billionaire if she had taken that Bitcoin. And you know, you hear the story, and even if you don't know anything about cryptocurrencies, you ask yourself, am I missing out by not getting in on this?
这听起来像电影的情节。如果我要拍那部电影，我会加入的一个子情节是歌手莉莉·艾伦的故事。莉莉·艾伦曾收到一份用比特币支付演出费的提议。她拒绝了。那是你能想象到的最重大的错误，因为如果她接受了那些比特币，她现在就是亿万富翁了。你知道，你听到这个故事，即使你对加密货币一无所知，你也会问自己，我因为没有参与其中而错过了什么吗？
I mean, the story induces phomo. That's exactly right. And that's a strong emotion. It's regret theory. People are fearful of being regretful that they miss something. It hurts. You don't want to look forward to that pain in the future. So you might as well try.
我的意思是，这个故事引发了错失恐惧症（FOMO）。完全正确。这是一种强烈的情绪。这就是后悔理论。人们害怕因为错过某事而感到后悔。这很痛苦。你不想在未来期待那种痛苦。所以你最好试一试。
That's the thinking. What's astonishing is that the craze of a Bitcoin spread, even though very few people actually understand what a cryptocurrency is, or understand its underlying blockchain technology. But these terms very quickly became buzzwords. Here's comedian John Oliver on last week tonight. Problem is, there is down
这就是那种想法。令人惊讶的是，比特币的狂热传播开来，尽管很少有人真正理解什么是加密货币，或者理解其底层的区块链技术。但这些术语很快就变成了流行语。这是喜剧演员约翰·奥利弗在《上周今夜》节目中的表现。问题是，有
enough excitement around the very word blockchain that has become a magnet for investment. Reuters found that existing companies that merely added the word block chain to their name saw their stock price on average increase more than three folds, and one of them was particularly dumb. Long Islander's T, renamed themselves long block chain, and guess what happened?
足够的兴奋围绕着“区块链”这个词，它已经成为了投资的磁铁。路透社发现，那些仅仅在名字中加入“区块链”一词的现有公司，其股价平均上涨了三倍多，其中一家特别愚蠢。长岛冰茶公司（Long Island Iced Tea）更名为长区块链（Long Blockchain），猜猜发生了什么？
Yeah, there's stock triple. Robert, so you read at one point that the total value of Bitcoin exceeded $300 billion, but Bitcoin has no value unless people think it has value. So something that existed purely in people's heads went from being worth $0 to $300 billion? Yes, it can easily happen if the viral effect is strong enough. Now, the Bitcoin enthusiasts will say, well, what about gold? Gold has no real value, just a shiny metal,
是的，他们的股票翻了三倍。罗伯特，你曾提到比特币的总价值一度超过3000亿美元，但除非人们认为比特币有价值，否则它毫无价值。所以一个纯粹存在于人们头脑中的东西，从价值0美元变成了3000亿美元？是的，如果病毒式传播效应足够强，这很容易发生。现在，比特币爱好者会说，那黄金呢？黄金没有实际价值，只是一种闪亮的金属，
pretty to look at, and yet it has tremendous value, and it has for thousands of years. But I have to say there's some differences. Gold is scarce, inherently scarce. Anybody can start a new cryptocurrency. Gold is in the Bible. It's mentioned over 300 times in the Holy Bible. You know, I was thinking about this as I was reading the book. You know, when I think about real money, obviously real money, you know, has on many occasions bought me real things. but at some level, doesn't real
看起来很漂亮，但它却有巨大的价值，而且已经持续了数千年。但我必须说，它们之间有一些区别。黄金是稀缺的，天生稀缺。任何人都可以启动一种新的加密货币。黄金在《圣经》中就有记载。它在《圣经》中被提到了300多次。你知道，我在读这本书时就在想这个问题。你知道，当我想到真正的钱时，显然真正的钱在很多场合为我买到了真正的东西。但在某种程度上，难道真正的
money function a little bit like Bitcoin in that it requires you and I to both agree that the notes that I have in my wallet have real value. That in some ways, we both agree on the story of what the notes mean and the story is what gives the notes their power. That's right. You've spoken just perfectly about narrative economics. I'll give you another example. Banks.
钱不像比特币那样运作吗？它需要你我都同意我钱包里的钞票具有真正的价值。在某种程度上，我们都同意关于这些钞票意味着什么的叙事，而正是这个故事赋予了钞票力量。没错。你刚才完美地阐述了叙事经济学。我再给你举个例子。银行。
Why don't banks fail? All it takes is a story. If someone says the bank is going to be bankrupt soon, everybody will rush in and try to take their money out. And the banks can't, they don't have it on hand. They can't pay it out. So that's another example of how, yes, our whole banking system is built on a narrative.
为什么银行不会倒闭？只需要一个故事。如果有人说银行很快就会破产，每个人都会冲进去试图把钱取出来。而银行做不到，他们手头没有那么多现金。他们无法支付。所以这是另一个例子，是的，我们整个银行系统都是建立在叙事之上的。
Yeah, because at any given point, the bank might have enough money cash on hand to basically pay out, you know, five or 10% of what its total assets are, it's investing the rest of the money in other projects of everyone asked for their money back at the same time, the bank would simply not be able to deliver. And it happens, and it's supported by visual imagery. Photographers go to the bank and they take a photograph of the big crowd clamoring to
是的，因为在任何给定的时间点，银行手头可能只有足够的现金来支付其总资产的5%或10%，其余的钱都投资在其他项目中。如果每个人同时要求取回他们的钱，银行根本无法交付。这种情况确实会发生，而且有视觉图像的支持。摄影师去银行拍摄一大群人吵着要
get in, to get their money out. This has happened so many times that the FDIC, Federal Deposit Insurance Company, has a gallery of photos in one of their residences. And so it's become a narrative in itself that we have to watch out for, that it doesn't come back. It's a perennial narrative. So Bitcoin was not just a mysterious new scheme. It tapped into many deep and ancient narratives about ordinary people and elites about
进去取钱的照片。这种情况发生过太多次，以至于联邦存款保险公司（FDIC）在他们的住所里有一个照片画廊。所以这本身已经成为了一种我们需要警惕的叙事，以免它卷土重来。这是一个永恒的叙事。所以比特币不仅仅是一个神秘的新计划。它利用了许多关于普通人和精英、关于
anarchy, about populism. Talk to me about those larger themes that are tapped into. Well, there was a movement that began in the 19th century with the philosopher Prudon called anarchism, which took an extreme statement that we don't need any government. If we just leave the people alone with no government, they will do much better. People are naturally inclined, many people, to anarchism. And so they're so happy to hear Bitcoin. Which was claimed can't be controlled by the government, because Bitcoin is for the whole world. It just sounds so enlightened and brilliant.
无政府主义、关于民粹主义的深刻而古老的叙事。跟我谈谈那些被利用的更大主题。嗯，19世纪出现了一场运动，由哲学家蒲鲁东发起，称为无政府主义，它采取了一种极端的说法，即我们不需要任何政府。如果我们只是让人们独自生活，没有政府，他们会做得更好。人们天生倾向于无政府主义，很多人都是这样。所以他们很高兴听到比特币。据称它不能被政府控制，因为比特币是为全世界准备的。这听起来太开明、太聪明了。
And in some ways, if you feel like you're part of the large number of people who doesn't have power, who doesn't have a voice, then you feel like powerful elites are running your life, as many people do. In some ways, Bitcoin is, you know, it's sort of you're throwing a rock against the edifice of the elites. You're basically fighting back in some ways. Right, and when you buy Bitcoin, you feel like you're on the bright side of things. You're an owner of some of this fancy computer stuff in a sense. Yeah. And you're part of it. Yeah, you're one of the disruptors, you're not the ones being disrupted.
在某种程度上，如果你觉得自己是广大没有权力、没有话语权的人群中的一员，如果你觉得强大的精英在掌控你的生活，就像许多人感觉的那样。在某种程度上，比特币就像是你向精英的大厦投掷了一块石头。你基本上是在以某种方式反击。没错，当你购买比特币时，你会觉得你站在了光明的一面。从某种意义上说，你是这些时髦计算机东西的所有者。是的。而且你是其中的一部分。是的，你是颠覆者之一，而不是被颠覆的人。
That's the hope that it gives you, yes. That's the hope that it gives you, yes. Robert says these underlying currents help explain why a story like Bitcoin took off. If psychology and sociology explain the origins of economic fads, Robert draws an idea from another field, medicine, to understand how such fads spread and when they die. Stories, he says, function like viruses or parasites. They spread only when they have a receptive host. It is really important to understand that things that are popular are the result of contagion.
这就是它给你的希望，是的。这就是它给你的希望，是的。罗伯特说，这些潜在的电流有助于解释为什么像比特币这样的故事会流行起来。如果心理学和社会学解释了经济时尚的起源，罗伯特从另一个领域——医学——借鉴了一个想法，来理解这些时尚是如何传播以及何时消亡的。他说，故事就像病毒或寄生虫。它们只有在有易感宿主时才会传播。理解流行事物是传染的结果，这一点非常重要。
There is a contagion rate, which varies through time. There's also a recovery rate, How soon people forget about the narrative. This is just straight out of medical epidemiology. The contagion rate has to be higher than the recovery rate and then the epidemic will take off. It'll start small, but it will get bigger and bigger. Until the contagion rate falls down below the recovery rate and then it starts to recede.
有一个传染率，它随时间而变化。还有一个恢复率，即人们多久会忘记这个叙事。这完全出自医学流行病学。传染率必须高于恢复率，然后流行病才会爆发。它会从小规模开始，但会越来越大。直到传染率降到恢复率以下，然后它就开始消退。
It's mysterious because we don't normally think rate falls down below the recovery rate and then it starts to recede. It's mysterious because we don't normally think about the contagion rate and the recovery rate for stories. But that in fact are basic parameters that explain when they get strong and when they fade away. And of course, for the people who haven't invested in Bitcoin, who didn't get in on the craze, you know, those people might listen to this and say, hang on a second, I wasn't affected by the story, but in some ways that's not different from an epidemic, not everyone falls sick when an epidemic is raging.
这很神秘，因为我们通常不会认为传染率降到恢复率以下，然后它就开始消退。这很神秘，因为我们通常不会考虑故事的传染率和恢复率。但事实上，这些是解释它们何时变得强大以及何时消退的基本参数。当然，对于那些没有投资比特币、没有参与这场狂热的人来说，你知道，这些人可能会听了这些说，等一下，我没有受到这个故事的影响，但在某种程度上，这与流行病没有什么不同，并不是每个人在流行病肆虐时都会生病。
Yeah, so if you have not invested in Bitcoin, that's not necessarily a sign of your common sense, it's just that you never encountered a contagious person who's spreading the word. Bitcoin is a single story. When we come back, Robert Schiller makes the case that narrative economics can explain larger phenomena, including shifts in the entire economy. Robert, in your book, you write, when we choose to tell a story to others, we base that choice on our perceptions of how people will react to that story in their own minds. We will likely spread a story, whether it
是的，所以如果你没有投资比特币，那并不一定是你常识的体现，只是你从未遇到过传播这个消息的传染源。比特币是一个单一的故事。回来后，罗伯特·席勒将论证叙事经济学可以解释更大的现象，包括整个经济的转变。罗伯特，在你的书中，你写道，当我们选择向他人讲述一个故事时，我们基于对人们在自己头脑中如何反应的感知来做出选择。我们很可能会传播一个故事，无论它
is a story about boom time thinking or about economic despair, if we think that others will like the story enough to want to spread it further. Talk about this idea that part of the reason story is spread, and some story is spread more than others, is that we are actually each of us gauging whether if we tell the story to somebody else, they in turn would want to pass it on. Right, well, it's what psychologists call theory of mind. That is, we are always thinking about what we imagine other people are thinking. That's because understanding other people's thinking is very important for success in
是一个关于繁荣时期思维的故事，还是关于经济绝望的故事，如果我们认为其他人会足够喜欢这个故事，以至于想要进一步传播它。谈谈这个想法，即故事传播的部分原因，以及有些故事比其他故事传播得更广，是因为我们每个人实际上都在衡量，如果我们把这个故事告诉别人，他们是否会愿意传下去。没错，这就是心理学家所说的“心智理论”。也就是说，我们总是在思考我们想象中别人在想什么。这是因为理解他人的想法对于在
human society. People enjoy conversation. It's part of our species. It's everywhere in the world. Everywhere you go, you'll see people standing, facing each other, engaged in conversation. It's part of our species. It's everywhere in the world. Everywhere you go, you'll see people standing facing each other engaged in conversation. And if you get a translation of what they're saying, they're telling stories. And people, when they hear a story, they turn it over in their mind and say, maybe I could use this story in another conversation. So people evaluate them based on their apparent success in motivating other people.
人类社会中取得成功非常重要。人们喜欢交谈。这是我们物种的一部分。它在世界各地随处可见。无论你走到哪里，你都会看到人们站着，面对面，进行交谈。这是我们物种的一部分。它在世界各地随处可见。无论你走到哪里，你都会看到人们站着面对面进行交谈。如果你翻译他们说的话，他们是在讲故事。当人们听到一个故事时，他们会在脑海中反复思考，并说，也许我可以在另一次谈话中使用这个故事。所以人们根据它们在激励他人方面的明显成功来评估它们。
So yeah, as if people are all trying to go viral. It's not a new thing with the internet. They were going viral thousands of years ago. Nearly a century ago, a powerful story swept the country. It's a story that has echoes in our own time, and the lessons from history are instructive. In the 1920s and 30s, many people feared that technological innovations were going to disrupt the economy and put lots of people out of work. For the majority, it means the interminable line outside factory gates, desperately hoping for a job that will rarely come. It explains some things that got out of hand and bad. The great depression of the 1930s came shortly after the term technological unemployment became popular in the late 1920s
所以是的，好像每个人都在试图让故事病毒式传播。这不是互联网带来的新事物。几千年前它们就在病毒式传播了。近一个世纪前，一个强大的故事席卷了全国。这是一个在我们这个时代也有回响的故事，历史的教训具有启发性。在20世纪20年代和30年代，许多人担心技术创新会扰乱经济，导致许多人失业。对于大多数人来说，这意味着工厂大门外无休止的队伍，绝望地希望得到一份几乎不会到来的工作。它解释了一些失控和糟糕的事情。20世纪30年代的大萧条发生在“技术性失业”这个词在20世纪20年代末流行之后不久
about machines replacing jobs new machines replaced old machines new invention the electric light automobile telephone started as luxuries then as they were made better and cheaper became and when the unemployment rate got high after 1930 people started to think this is it. It's robots replacing our jobs. You may think it's pretty strange that people thought about robots in 1930. That sounds like long before they had computers.
关于机器取代工作，新机器取代旧机器，新发明，电灯、汽车、电话最初是奢侈品，然后随着它们变得更好、更便宜，当1930年后失业率变高时，人们开始认为就是这样。是机器人在取代我们的工作。你可能觉得人们在1930年就想到机器人很奇怪。这听起来像是远在他们拥有计算机之前。
But they did think they had robots. I'll give you an example of what they called a robot. It's the dial telephone. Before that, when you picked up a phone, there was no dial, no keypad. You had to just, there was an operator there and it would say, number please. Number please.
但他们确实认为他们有机器人。我给你举一个他们称之为机器人的例子。那就是拨号电话。在此之前，当你拿起电话时，没有拨号盘，没有键盘。你必须，那里有一个接线员，它会说，请报号码。请报号码。
They replaced that operator with a machine. That's called a robot. And it's scared people then. And they thought that maybe we better pull back and save some more money. When everybody does that, it makes the depression worse. So one of the interesting points you make is that stories vanish and resurface like the story you're just telling about technological innovation, displacing workers.
他们用机器取代了那个接线员。这就叫机器人。这在当时吓坏了人们。他们认为也许我们最好退缩，多存点钱。当每个人都这样做时，就会使萧条变得更糟。所以你提出的一个有趣的观点是，故事会像你刚才讲述的关于技术创新取代工人的故事一样消失并重新出现。
And sometimes these stories vanish and come back over decades or even centuries and that really is analogous to what happens with pathogens that go dormant and then they reemerge sometimes decades later as epidemics. That's right and a pathogen can reemerge because of a mutation like influenza mutates quite regularly and we have to get inoculated imperfectly against those mutations. Or it can change because of some change in our practices. If there's some event that brings people closer together
有时这些故事会消失，并在几十年甚至几个世纪后回来，这确实类似于病原体发生的情况，它们进入休眠状态，然后有时几十年后作为流行病重新出现。没错，病原体可能会因为突变而重新出现，比如流感会定期变异，我们必须针对这些突变进行不完美的接种。或者它可能会因为我们行为的某种改变而改变。如果有什么事件让人们更紧密地聚集在一起
in an enclosed space, it can spread much more rapidly and the contagion rate goes up. So these are fundamental lessons that I don't hear very often from most economists. They don't talk in these terms. And they don't see the causal impact from narratives to the economy. So it's interesting when we think about stories, if you draw the analogy with pathogens, perhaps then modifications to stories or tweaks in an underlying story might be necessary for a dormant story to come back and become dominant again. Yes, and so sometimes the tweaks are just frivolousous sounding. I'll give an example from my book,
在封闭的空间里，它传播得更快，传染率就会上升。所以这些是大多数经济学家不常提到的基本教训。他们不以这些术语交谈。他们看不到从叙事到经济的因果影响。所以当我们思考故事时，如果我们用病原体做类比，那么也许对故事的修改或对潜在故事的微调对于一个休眠的故事回归并再次成为主导可能是必要的。是的，所以有时这些微调听起来很轻浮。我从我的书中举个例子，
the idea of trickle-down economics where you cut taxes on the rich, on the theory that they will raise GDP, and ultimately enrich the poorer people, was starting to look pretty old by the 1970s. But then a new narrative appeared then, really written by writer Jude Wynisky, about the Laffer curve. And it was basically the same theory
涓滴经济学的想法，即你削减富人的税收，理论上他们会提高GDP，并最终使穷人致富，到20世纪70年代看起来已经很老了。但随后出现了一个新的叙事，实际上是由作家裘德·万尼斯基（Jude Wanniski）撰写的，关于拉弗曲线。这基本上是同一个理论
that if you cut taxes, GDP will go up, and tax revenues will even go up. You just have to cut taxes. That was a lovely story, and it was embellished by details, visual images. Like it was said that Arthur Laffer, the economist, presented his idea, a new idea about taxes in the form of a diagram which he drew out on napkin at a fancy restaurant with Defense Secretary Donald Rumsfeld and future Vice president Dick Cheney, putting these names at a visual image of a diagram drawn on a napkin, was all that that narrative needed to get
即如果你减税，GDP就会上升，税收收入甚至会增加。你只需要减税。那是一个可爱的故事，它被细节、视觉图像所修饰。比如有人说经济学家阿瑟·拉弗（Arthur Laffer）在一家高档餐厅里，与国防部长唐纳德·拉姆斯菲尔德（Donald Rumsfeld）和未来的副总统迪克·切尼（Dick Cheney）一起，在餐巾纸上画了一个图表，展示了他的新税收想法，将这些名字与画在餐巾纸上的图表的视觉图像联系起来，就是那个叙事再次引发
epidemic again. And that led to, I would say, Margaret Fatcher's ascendance to the Prime Minister in Britain in 1979, and then Ronald Reagan, president of the United States, both tax cutters. So the diagram drawn on that napkin eventually came to be called the Laffer curve. Explain what that curve is. Explain what the very simple intuition is behind that curve that eventually led to fairly significant policy changes on both sides of the Atlantic. Yeah, it's almost a laffer curve story.
流行病所需要的一切。这导致了，我想说，玛格丽特·撒切尔在1979年当选英国首相，然后是罗纳德·里根，美国总统，两人都是减税者。所以那张餐巾纸上画的图表最终被称为拉弗曲线。解释一下那条曲线是什么。解释一下那条曲线背后非常简单的直觉，它最终导致了大西洋两岸相当重大的政策变化。是的，这几乎是一个拉弗曲线的故事。
It's almost like a joke with a punchline. So what Laffer said is, if we have a 0% tax rate on incomes, how much will we collect? Zero, obviously. But what if we have a 100% tax rate on incomes? What will we collect? Well, it'll be zero again, because nobody's going to work if the government takes all of it. So in between, revenue has to be positive.
这几乎就像一个带笑话的笑话。所以拉弗说的是，如果我们对收入征收0%的税率，我们将征收多少？显然是零。但如果我们对收入征收100%的税率呢？我们将征收多少？好吧，那又会是零，因为如果政府拿走全部，没人会去工作。所以在这两者之间，收入必须是正的。
So connect the dots, and you have a hump shaped curve. That means that to raise any given amount of revenue, there are always two tax rates, a low one and a high one. You can picture that on my diagram, which I'm asking you to make a mental image of. And so that's a new idea. Nobody's been talking about two tax rates to raise the same revenue. It's clever. It's like a stunt, a trick. It's a magic trick. It's fun. You can have, you'll know that you'll get a rise out of people if you explain it well enough and Tell such a story. So it went absolutely viral not just in the United States. It spread all over the world
所以把点连起来，你就得到了一个驼峰状的曲线。这意味着要筹集任何给定的收入，总有两个税率，一个低的和一个高的。你可以在我的图表上想象这一点，我要求你在脑海中形成一个图像。所以这是一个新想法。没人谈论过用两个税率来筹集相同的收入。这很聪明。这就像一个特技，一个把戏。这是一个魔术。这很有趣。如果你解释得足够好并讲述这样一个故事，你会知道你会引起人们的兴趣。所以它绝对病毒式传播了，不仅仅是在美国。它传播到了全世界
It might be hard to visualize this curve, but think about it this way As Robert says the government raises zero dollars in taxes when the taxation rate is zero But also when it is 100%. Think of what would happen if the tax rate was 1% or 99%. In both cases, the government would raise only a small amount of money. When it's 1%, a lot of people would go to work, but the government would get only a small portion of their income. When it's 99%, the government would also get very little, because only a few people would work when 99 cents of every dollar are taken away from them. You can imagine the same dynamic playing out at other levels of taxation.
可能很难想象这条曲线，但可以这样想：正如罗伯特所说，当税率为0%时，政府征收的税款为零，但当税率为100%时也是如此。想想如果税率是1%或99%会发生什么。在这两种情况下，政府都只会筹集到少量的钱。当税率是1%时，很多人会去工作，但政府只会得到他们收入的一小部分。当税率是99%时，政府也会得到很少，因为当每1美元中有99美分被拿走时，只有少数人会工作。你可以想象同样的动态在其他税收水平上发挥作用。
The intuitive idea here is that they can be two levels of taxation that produce the same amount of revenue. If that's the case, you can make everyone happy by taxing people at the lower rate. You gotta give Art Laffer credit for that. Seems obvious now. And it had big profound effects. It was a big epidemic in the 70s and early 80s. But it's coming back now.
这里的直觉是，可以有两个产生相同收入的税收水平。如果是这样，你可以通过以较低的税率征税来让每个人都高兴。你得给阿特·拉弗（Art Laffer）点赞。现在看起来很明显。它产生了巨大而深远的影响。这是70年代和80年代初的一场大流行。但它现在又回来了。
Arthur Laffer is still there and he's still gloating in his great success. That was the best thing he ever did in terms of narrative quality. So is it true that Art Laffer himself has debunked the story about the napkin and the story with Don Rumsfeld and Dick Cheney in the restaurant in Washington? Well, the National Museum of American History in Washington was designing an exhibit on
阿瑟·拉弗还在那里，他还在为自己的巨大成功而沾沾自喜。就叙事质量而言，这是他做过的最好的事情。那么阿特·拉弗本人是否真的揭穿了关于餐巾纸的故事，以及在华盛顿餐厅里与唐·拉姆斯菲尔德和迪克·切尼的故事？嗯，华盛顿的国家美国历史博物馆正在设计一个关于
business history. And they had the idea that it would be good to get the napkin. And maybe, well, Jude Wyniski, the author of the story, had died. They called his widow and asked her, we're looking for a napkin with a diagram drawn on it. Can you look around his things? And then she called back and said, yes, I found an African with a diagram, so she gave it to them. And they proudly put it in their display. You can find it searching on the web.
商业历史的展览。他们认为如果能得到那张餐巾纸会很好。也许，嗯，故事的作者裘德·万尼斯基已经去世了。他们打电话给他的遗孀，问她，我们正在寻找一张上面画有图表的餐巾纸。你能看看他的东西吗？然后她回电话说，是的，我找到了一张画有图表的餐巾纸，所以她给了他们。他们自豪地把它放在了展示柜里。你可以在网上搜索找到它。
And they tell you they're very proud to have this exhibit. But there's one problem with it that a reporter later called Art Laffer and asked him about it. And he said, I don't believe that story. He said, I don't remember writing on a napkin, and moreover, my mother taught me, it would be a cloth napkin at a fine restaurant. My mother taught me not to do such things.
他们告诉你他们非常自豪能有这个展品。但它有一个问题，后来一位记者打电话给阿特·拉弗问他这件事。他说，我不相信那个故事。他说，我不记得在餐巾纸上写过字，而且，我母亲教过我，在高档餐厅里那会是布餐巾。我母亲教我不要做这种事。
Well, I mean, what's fascinating, of course, is that it's such a good story, and it's such a fun story and it's such a fun story that it almost feels a pity to apply the facts to it and debunk it. And that applies to conversation generally. How many people actually fact check their stories when they tell them? The Laffer curve is still being debated by economists. While the curve might make sense at the ends of the taxation spectrum,
嗯，我的意思是，当然令人着迷的是，这是一个如此好的故事，这是一个如此有趣的故事，以至于应用事实去揭穿它几乎让人感到遗憾。这适用于一般的谈话。有多少人在讲故事时真的核实过事实？拉弗曲线仍然受到经济学家的争论。虽然这条曲线在税收范围的两端可能说得通，
it might not describe what people do at realistic levels of taxation. Most governments aren't choosing between a tax rate of 10% and a tax rate of 90%, they're choosing between 25% and 30%. That means drawing implications from the Lafayette curve might not make much sense. But in the 1980s, the story of the Lafayette curve proved irresistible. Cauls to reduce taxation were buttressed by other stories, like this one from President Ronald Reagan, to showcase wastewill government spending. In Chicago, they found a woman who holds the record. She used 80 names, 30 addresses, 15 telephone numbers to collect food stamps, social security, veterans benefits for four non-existent deceased veterans husbands, as well as well as
它可能无法描述人们在现实税收水平下的行为。大多数政府不是在10%的税率和90%的税率之间做选择，而是在25%和30%之间做选择。这意味着从拉弗曲线中得出结论可能没有多大意义。但在20世纪80年代，拉弗曲线的故事被证明是不可抗拒的。减少税收的呼声得到了其他故事的支持，比如罗纳德·里根总统的这个故事，以展示浪费的政府支出。在芝加哥，他们发现了一个保持记录的女人。她使用了80个名字、30个地址、15个电话号码来领取食品券、社会保障、为四个不存在的已故退伍军人丈夫领取的退伍军人福利，以及
a couple of other women. So Robert tell me how Reagan's story is about so-called welfare queens intersected with these ideas from the Laffer curve and eventually changed federal policy. Yeah, well Reagan was a good storyteller by the way. So he had great deal of power from that. That kind of story elicits anger. And anger is a strong emotion.
其他几个女人。所以罗伯特，告诉我里根关于所谓的“福利女王”的故事是如何与拉弗曲线的这些想法交叉，并最终改变了联邦政策的。是的，顺便说一句，里根是一个很好的讲故事的人。所以他从中获得了巨大的力量。那种故事会引发愤怒。而愤怒是一种强烈的情绪。
But the problem with that story is it's not a statistic. It's just, in fact, it's the record holder. So that means there's only one like her. But storytellers don't care. They tell anomalous and rare events as if they're common. And if it's contagious like that, it generates fake news. You were talking a second ago about how President Reagan, in some ways, was a marvelous story teller. One of his stories affected not just how individuals and companies act, but perhaps even how nations act. He liked to tell a story about the failures of communism and Soviet Russia, where people had to wait for years to get routine household services.
但那个故事的问题在于它不是一个统计数据。它只是，事实上，她是记录保持者。所以这意味着只有一个像她这样的人。但讲故事的人不在乎。他们把反常和罕见的事件当作普遍现象来讲述。如果它像那样具有传染性，它就会产生假新闻。你刚才谈到里根总统在某种程度上是一位了不起的讲故事的人。他的一个故事不仅影响了个人和公司的行为，甚至可能影响了国家的行为。他喜欢讲一个关于共产主义和苏联失败的故事，在那里人们必须等待多年才能获得常规的家庭服务。
In one joke he told to many audiences, he described a man who goes to buy a car and is told he has to wait for 10 years. That this man, he laid down his money and then the fellow, he was in charge, said to him, okay, come back in 10 years and get your car. And he said, morning or afternoon. And the fellow behind the car said, well, 10 years from now, what difference does it make? And he said, well, the plumber is coming in the morning. And what is so effective here, Robert, is that Reagan is not saying explicitly communism doesn't work, that message is embedded inside the joke and that's the power of the story.
在他对许多听众讲的一个笑话中，他描述了一个人去买车，被告知必须等10年。这个人，他付了钱，然后负责的那个人对他说，好吧，10年后回来拿你的车。他说，上午还是下午？车后的那个人说，好吧，10年后，有什么区别吗？他说，好吧，水管工上午要来。罗伯特，这里如此有效的是，里根并没有明确说共产主义行不通，那个信息嵌入在笑话中，这就是故事的力量。
Yeah, and it also shows an example of the tendency for stories to go viral that are associated with a celebrity. The real author of that story is someone living in Russia, I suppose, who gets no credit for it. It really goes viral when it's connected with someone that we know. And that's just the way we are. Lots of famous quotes in history turn out not to have been first said by the famous person. The famous person was quoting somebody else that he doesn't care about. Yeah, and isn't it also the case that sometimes the stories might not even be true? I mean, we don't even know whether there actually was a specific person in the Soviet Union who came up with this.
是的，它也展示了与名人相关的故事病毒式传播的倾向。那个故事的真正作者是住在俄罗斯的某个人，我想，他没有得到任何赞誉。当它与我们认识的人联系在一起时，它才会真正病毒式传播。这就是我们的样子。历史上的许多名言最终被证明并不是由名人首先说的。名人是在引用别人，他并不在乎那个人。是的，而且有时这些故事甚至可能不是真的，不是吗？我的意思是，我们甚至不知道苏联是否真的有特定的人想出了这个。
There have been questions raised about the welfare queen story that Reagan told, for example. And in some ways, once a story is traveling and it's embedded, the truth is often not sufficient to demolish it. Yes, and this is not a new problem. It goes way back. If you turn on the news these days, there is a powerful story that's in circulation that tells us that a long period of economic expansion is soon going to be over. Although things may look good for now, many Wall Street analysts are concerned about the warning signs ahead.
例如，关于里根讲述的福利女王故事，人们曾提出过质疑。在某种程度上，一旦一个故事在传播并且已经根深蒂固，真相往往不足以摧毁它。是的，这不是一个新问题。它由来已久。如果你这些天打开新闻，有一个强大的故事正在流传，告诉我们长期的经济扩张很快就要结束了。尽管目前情况看起来不错，但许多华尔街分析师对前方的警告信号感到担忧。
Recessioning light now is washing for the first time since 2017. As a key predictor of recession, we need to announce the hot market's price. Once again, you've washing that ominous recession warning signal. The economy could be head out of the soil following 800 points. It was in 3% of its value. What do you tell people when they ask you to predict the next recession? And by the way, that's me indirectly asking you
衰退信号现在是自2017年以来首次出现。作为衰退的关键预测指标，我们需要宣布热门市场的价格。再一次，你看到了那个不祥的衰退警告信号。经济可能会在下跌800点后走出困境。它损失了3%的价值。当人们要求你预测下一次衰退时，你会告诉他们什么？顺便说一句，那是我间接地要求你
to predict the next recession. My feeling is that we are at a heightened risk of a recession. And having a recession before the 2020 elections in the US might even be 50%. You'll see a clear evidence of a recession coming. But I can't go above that. There will be another recession.
预测下一次衰退。我的感觉是，我们处于衰退风险加剧的状态。在美国2020年大选前出现衰退的可能性甚至可能是50%。你会看到衰退即将来临的明确证据。但我不能超过那个数字。会有另一次衰退。
We know that. But the other question that people tend to talk about all or nothing, will we or will we now have a recession? The question is, if there is another question which I like to entertain, if there is a recession, is there a chance that it will develop into a severe recession? And I'm worried about that, even though I can't tell you precisely whether it will be in a recession, and I think there are narratives today that might worsen a recession,
我们知道这一点。但人们倾向于谈论的另一个问题是全有或全无，我们是否会衰退？问题是，如果还有另一个我喜欢探讨的问题，如果发生衰退，它是否有机会发展成严重的衰退？我对此感到担忧，尽管我无法准确告诉你是否会陷入衰退，但我认为今天有一些叙事可能会加剧衰退，
notably the artificial intelligence narrative, which in an earlier form in the Great Depression really did heightened the impact of the depression. We could see that again, people becoming conservative in their expenditure because they're afraid of losing their jobs. I mean, it's already going on in some parts of the country, but it could become big. One point that Robert makes is that the veracity of economic narratives is not the point. Stories can invent their own reality.
特别是人工智能叙事，它在大萧条时期的早期形式确实加剧了萧条的影响。我们可能会再次看到这种情况，人们因为害怕失业而变得保守。我的意思是，这在全国部分地区已经发生了，但它可能会变得很大。罗伯特提出的一个观点是，经济叙事的真实性并不是重点。故事可以发明它们自己的现实。
One example he gives is the narrative around Japan's last decade, a period of economic stagnation during the 1990s and early 2000s. The last decade story for Japan was particularly impactful since it followed the 1980s when Japan was considered the economic powerhouse of the world. People were saying that nobody can compete with Japan. They've pushed out Western makers of cameras, stereo equipment, they're hammering away at their sales of cars, and there were books written back then about the Japanese miracle. And then suddenly it went sour in the 1990s.
他给出的一个例子是关于日本“失去的十年”的叙事，这是20世纪90年代和21世纪初经济停滞的一段时期。日本“失去的十年”的故事特别有影响力，因为它发生在20世纪80年代之后，当时日本被认为是世界的经济强国。人们说没有人能与日本竞争。他们挤走了西方的相机、音响设备制造商，他们正在猛烈抨击汽车销售，当时还有关于“日本奇迹”的书籍。然后它在90年代突然变味了。
I'm wondering if President Donald Trump might be a fan of your book, whether or not he's actually read it, because he clearly also believes in the power of stories. Here he is talking down the risks of an impending recession. I don't think we're having a recession. We're doing tremendously well. Our consumers are rich. I gave a tremendous tax cut, and they're loaded up with money.
我想知道唐纳德·特朗普总统是否可能是你书的粉丝，无论他是否真的读过它，因为他显然也相信故事的力量。这是他在淡化即将到来的衰退风险。我不认为我们会陷入衰退。我们做得非常好。我们的消费者很富有。我给了巨大的减税，他们口袋里装满了钱。
They're buying. I saw the Walmart numbers. They were through the roof just two days ago. That's better than any poll. That's better than any economist. So Robert, given what you say about how talk and shape economic reality is president trump absolutely right to be spinning a positive story
他们在购买。我看到了沃尔玛的数据。就在两天前，它们简直爆表了。这比任何民意调查都好。这比任何经济学家都好。所以罗伯特，鉴于你所说的关于谈话如何塑造经济现实，特朗普总统在编造一个积极的故事方面绝对正确吗？
well i i wouldn't use the word absolutely right that's a little strong but he is having an impact i believe uh... it's not just his current spinning of the story he's written many books with co-authors the the the these books uh... his current spinning of the story. He's written many books with co-authors. These books have advice to be like him. He tells you how he did it. He tells you, for example, don't be afraid to boast about yourself because people are maybe a little resentful about boasting people, but in the long run, they believe in them because if you don't
嗯，我不会用“绝对正确”这个词，那有点太绝对了，但我相信他确实产生了影响。这不仅仅是他目前对故事的编造，他与人合著过许多书。这些书里有关于如何变得像他一样的建议。他告诉你他是怎么做到的。例如，他告诉你，不要害怕吹嘘自己，因为人们可能对吹嘘的人有点反感，但从长远来看，他们会相信这些人，因为如果你不这样做，
boast, nobody will hear about your successes. This is Donald Trump talking. He's telling you to spread your personal narrative aggressively, and he's been doing that for himself for 50 years. And it's worked. Robert Schiller won the 2013 Nobel Prize in Economics. He's the author of Narrative Economics, How Stories Go Viral and Drive Major Economic Events. Robert, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Break. Shanko, thanks. It was a pleasure. This week's episode was produced by Thomas Liu and edited by Jenny Schmidt and Tara Boyer. Our team includes Parth Shah, Raina Cohen and Laura Quarell. Special thanks to Remco's Svetlot and Laura Beltran via Mitzar. A run-sang hero for this episode is Christian Kutten.
吹嘘，就没人会听说你的成功。这是唐纳德·特朗普在说话。他在告诉你积极地传播你的个人叙事，而他自己已经这样做了50年。而且这很有效。罗伯特·席勒获得了2013年诺贝尔经济学奖。他是《叙事经济学：故事如何传播并驱动重大经济事件》一书的作者。罗伯特，感谢你今天参加《隐藏的大脑》节目。尚卡尔，谢谢。很高兴能来。本周的节目由托马斯·刘制作，珍妮·施密特和塔拉·博耶编辑。我们的团队包括帕斯·沙阿、雷娜·科恩和劳拉·夸雷尔。特别感谢雷姆科·斯维特洛特和劳拉·贝尔特兰通过米扎尔提供帮助。本集的一位幕后英雄是克里斯蒂安·库滕。
Christian is NPR's financial controller. He and the talented accounting team at NPR make sure that bills get paid, revenues get collected, and the organization follows tax and accounting rules. Christian has helped me on many occasions, think through the financial models for Hidden Brain and the implications of different choices. He is great at seeing the stories behind the numbers and finding ways to tell those stories eloquently.
克里斯蒂安是NPR的财务总监。他和NPR才华横溢的会计团队确保账单得到支付，收入得到收取，并且组织遵循税务和会计规则。克里斯蒂安在很多场合都帮助我思考《隐藏的大脑》的财务模型以及不同选择的影响。他非常擅长从数字背后看到故事，并找到以雄辩的方式讲述这些故事的方法。
Thank you, Christian. For more Hidden Brain, you can follow us on Facebook and Twitter. If you liked this episode, please be sure to share it with a friend. It's all like you have a fun show. I like it. It is a fun show. You should subscribe, Robert. Alright.
谢谢你，克里斯蒂安。想了解更多《隐藏的大脑》内容，请在Facebook和Twitter上关注我们。如果你喜欢这一集，请务必与朋友分享。这就像你有一个有趣的节目。我喜欢它。这确实是一个有趣的节目。你应该订阅，罗伯特。好的。
Take care. I'm Shankar Vidantam and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
保重。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是NPR。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。